desde el aire la reserva indígena
yanomami aparece majestuosa situada en
el extremo norte de brasil en la
frontera con venezuela es una de las más
grandes del país tiene el mismo tamaño
que portugal
en sus noventa y seis mil kilómetros
cuadrados viven 28.000 yanomamis
repartidos en 366 aldeas casi todas
aisladas
a principios de julio las fuerzas
armadas llevaron la operación kobe 19 a
esta región uno de los cometidos era
abastecer a los indígenas con cuatro
toneladas de medicamentos y material
sanitario hay máscaras delantales
guantes pis y también tenemos cloroquina
es el polémico medicamento defendido por
el presidente jair bolsonaro pero eso no
significa que lo vamos a recetar para
tratar el commit 19 lo estamos llevando
porque es una región endémica de malaria
34 mil militares participan en esta
misión que arrancó el 19 de marzo con el
apoyo del ministerio de sanidad en
muchas de las 6.000 aldeas indígenas de
brasil las fuerzas armadas son la única
presencia tangible del estado
el coronavirus ha llegado desde hace
tiempo a la reserva yanomami los
indígenas culpan a los 20.000 buscadores
de oro que invaden ilegalmente sus
tierras en busca del precioso metal las
cifras oficiales
aumentan cada día al final de la
grabación de este reportaje había 305
contagios y 4 muertes
en la aldea de surf qq
los yanomami se protegen con mascarillas
de los forasteros
la aglomeración resulta inevitable el
problema es que no somos conscientes de
las distancias sanitarias que tenemos
que respetar aquí la gente crea muchas
aglomeraciones con sus parientes es un
día de mucha faena hay consulta de
medicina familiar pediatría y
ginecología uno de los objetivos de la
misión es que los indígenas no tengan
que desplazarse hasta la capital
boavista situada a 950 kilómetros de
distancia en busca de atención médica te
voy a examinar vale
quien presenta síntomas sospechosos debe
realizar un test rápido de coronavirus
pero este joven yanomami se resiste hay
un comprensible temor entre los
indígenas por intervenciones y
procedimientos con los que no están
familiarizados y que pueden ir en contra
de sus tradiciones
quieres hacerte el test de la cob y es
importante hacer el test para saber si
estás enfermos este enfermero se ofrece
como conejillo de indias sabe que tiene
que dar el ejemplo todo lo que es nuevo
genera en ellos un cierto malestar es
una nueva enfermedad y todavía están
aprendiendo lo que es la estrategia
funciona y el joven yanomami accede a
dejarse pinchar por razones logísticas
en el medio de la selva sólo se puede
realizar test rápidos es lo que podemos
hacer aquí pero si uno de los test
rápidos da positivo
nosotros vamos a indicar que se realice
el test psr la muestra debe ser enviada
a boavista la capital de roraima la
expedición sigue hacia el pueblo de
huaycán debajo de nosotros las minas
ilegales de oro karkom en la selva
aquí viven tan sólo 180 indígenas
yekuana un subgrupo de los yanomamis
esta pequeña aldea está cercada de
buscadores de oro que llegan
clandestinamente por barco y por aire
un joven indígena que llegó aquí desde
la ciudad junto a los garimpeiros llegó
con síntomas sospechosos viajó en el
barco de un buscador de oro
aquí es posible que haya propagado el
virus en dos días fueron realizados 209
tests rápidos y todos resultaron
negativos en una visita sorpresa a la
reserva yanomami el ministro de defensa
afirmó que la situación está bajo
control el gobierno no debería
intensificar su acción contra la
invasión de los buscadores de oro tratar
la causa de la enfermedad en vez de las
consecuencias mira este no es
competencia del ministerio de defensa
pero las fuerzas armadas son la única
presencia del estado estamos presentes y
hacemos lo que podemos
no es nuestra especialidad el día
después de nuestra visita la fiscalía
general abrió una investigación acerca
de la misión con 1.019 en las tierras
yanomami para averiguar si las fuerzas
armadas violaron el aislamiento
voluntario de los pueblos indígenas su
única protección contra el coronavirus y
también si fue distribuida la cloroquina
para tratar esta enfermedad
este joven yanomami se encargó de
protocolar la denuncia ante la fiscalía
desde boavista cuenta que fueron
confirmados 40 nuevos casos de
coronavirus tras la salida del ejército
de wake us un dato que el ministerio de
sanidad- niega
fue totalmente errado
visitar la tierra yanomami en medio de
la pandemia es muy peligroso
estoy seguro de que el ejército quiso
hacer una operación de marketing del
gobierno federal
a principios de julio un tribunal
federal determinó que el ejecutivo
retire de las tierras yanomami a los
buscadores de oro a los que bolsonaro
apoyado públicamente en varias ocasiones
nada se ha hecho desde entonces a la
lucha contra él garimpo ahora se suma la
dura batalla contra el coronavirus